hi there Steve here I'm back from
Montreal back from Long Fest never
really got a good night's sleep in
Montreal because of the three-hour time
difference and I'm still kind of half
asleep but I want to talk a bit about
the Arabic language which version of the
Arabic language I'm going to start to
focus on and how that ties into the long
fest so please bear with me at the end
of this my little diet monologue here
I'll show you an interview with the
person I met who is from Egypt and who
has influenced me in terms of my
direction of my Arabic language learning
but I first of all wanted to say that
the long Fest is festival day long that
they have in Montreal is a wonderful
event and there were speakers on many
different subjects motivation and
language learning techniques and
language learning
people like anya who teaches german
online and quick snapshot of her of
course the whole thing has been
organized by three people one of whom is
texan and you'll see a good friend of
mine from many years back and you'll see
a picture of him here with me and but
but the long fest the main thing about
it is that it's an incubator of
motivation people meet other people who
are learning different languages who
have different techniques different
approaches different resources tools
that they use content that they use in
fact one session we were engaging with
the other people in the audience to talk
about which are the good resources which
are the good tools so people come away
from this sort of charged up and ready
to you know go after their languages and
so then getting back to my strategy I
have to say that my my enthusiasm for
Arabic was flagging a bit you know I
arrived in Montreal and I'm picked up by
an obviously Arabic or possibly Arabic
looking taxi driver and I say a few
things to him in my modern Standard
Arabic and his comment was you know I
sort of understand you but my daughter
wouldn't understand
at all in other words no one speaks what
you're learning and I had this one other
time in a restaurant
somebody waiting for my table in that
little cafe and I said you know please
I'm in public I said I don't know if
that's right or wrong he kind of looked
at me and I said Minford like him you
know I'm learning Arabic it means please
I think oh yeah yeah yeah but I'm
Lebanese so I said well what am I doing
with this Arabic nobody speaks it and I
got quite keen on Farsi actually and I'm
still keen on Farsi and I'm going to
also do Farsi but then I met Heba whom
you're gonna meet shortly she traveled
all the way from Cairo Egypt to
participate in the lawn fest by far the
person who came the farthest away a very
pleasant person very helpful she's gonna
help me she's going to record our many
stories in Egyptian Arabic so I'll be
able to listen to these stories that
I've been listening to in modern
Standard Arabic now I'm gonna listen to
them in Egyptian Arabic she also was
full of advice on places to visit an
hour and Egypt and all the kind of stuff
all of this is very motivating so and
everyone has told me that the most
widely understood form of Arabic is
Egyptian Arabic because the movie
industry the entertainment industry etc
it's based in Egypt so all of the Arabic
speakers who speak their own versions of
Arabic in the Arab world they all watch
Egyptian TV programmes series and so
forth and my wife and I he even came
across an Egyptian version of Grand
Hotel which is this series we watched in
Spanish it's available in a Egyptian
Arabic so with help from Heba and others
if I can work my Egyptian Arabic up to a
certain level I might even be able to
watch that TV series so and my strand
there were some very nice Turkish people
there as well and Farsi speakers so my
strategy remains to go after the sort of
Middle East Central Asia Arabic Farsi
Turkey and of course the thing about
that area and particularly Egypt it's
not just the Arabic language it's the
history it's Egypt if I go there and I
can speak and then I can visit
you know the historical sites and so
forth so all of that is motivation so if
my goal is to learn three languages from
that region Egyptian at least Arabic
with an emphasis on Egyptian Arabic
Farsi and Turkish the only thing that is
going to prevent me from achieving that
goal will be time or lack of motivation
nor say three things the three things
motivation which right now is high time
and the third thing is sufficient
resources in that language that's
extremely important and those languages
which I do best in is those are the
languages where there's the greatest
amount of comprehensible input available
in that language so with that I'm gonna
let you watch the interview that I did
with HIPAA and oh I should say too I'll
also show I'll lead into that I had the
best of intentions of going around doing
a V log I don't understand all these
terms but it's interviewing people and
putting it up and stuff but yeah I'm not
I just can't seem I did it at the
beginning for like the first 10 minutes
but then I can't continue doing that
I'll just not into doing that and I
could talk to people hear what they have
to say I don't want to be video 8
videoing people and stuff so I put up a
couple of videos where with the best of
intentions I started keeping a record of
long fest and then we move on into the
interview with Heba and hopefully that
will give you a bit of a sense of the
long fest a sense of where I'm headed
with my language learning and also I
want to reinforce that that you know
with all of the presentations different
techniques of learning and so forth it
still comes down essentially - I would
say motivation time and the availability
of good accessible meaningful
comprehensible content that you can use
those are the things that matter in
language learning in my view of course
thank you bye for now
so this is day two of the long fest I've
just had my coffee and Casa and
neighborhood who launched leap and they
pee it's known as and last night I was
at de mundo lingo event where all kinds
of enthusiastic people were speaking all
kinds of different languages this is my
subway or Metro stop I'm about to jump
in the metro and head on down to the
long Fest and I will try to do videos
throughout the day I'm not presenting
today
I had a presentation yesterday one again
tomorrow so I'm gonna maybe interview
people and give you a sense of what the
long Fest is all about see you later
[Music]
we drain
got my handy book Farsi here I see mail
I got my subway Metro pass for the
weekend
and I'm all set to go here it is the
lobby and I walk in and the first person
I see is Rani Gow God we don't have good
lighting there but I see his tweets and
comments on the internet so we know each
other sort of virtually and now each
other for almost a decade is this your
first one fest
yes it is did it and where are you based
I'm based out of Toronto or your based
on the product and you are fairly active
on social media I think in a good way or
a bad way and you talk about language
right yes yeah okay one of the many
enthusiastic people participating along
president thank you
Thank You Christy I the long press is
wrapping up I have sitting with me here
Heba is ye who is the person who came
from the furthest away to attend the
long fest
because you started your journey in well
I started my journey and I think it's on
the 19th and the 20th but from Cairo yes
from Kairos came from Cairo just to
participate in the last it took me
actually 26 hours ago year we had people
from the states from Europe from Mexico
but comparable you were the furthest and
it's very timely because of course when
you come from the bockfest you meet all
kinds of people you have very pleasant
conversations everybody in doors
so and I think this is a very fateful
meeting because I was complaining about
learning trying to learn modern Standard
Arabic and nobody speaks modern Standard
Arabic so when am I going to learn
version of Arabic and which one should I
learn and Emmas advice is well well what
I said is that learning it for reading
is good but learning to use me then
choosing the Egyptian Arabic would be an
easy dialect because it's easier to pick
it's not so far from the modern Standard
and in the same time it's understood by
every speaker every Arabic speaking
person so you wouldn't feel that you
whenever you are speaking with someone
that you are not understood as long as
they understand Arabic they're gonna
sing the Egyptian Arabic and the other
attractions are that it's funny my wife
and I were watching Netflix and there's
of course different programs there and
we had watched this Grand Hotel which is
a series in Spanish and lo and behold it
shows up in in Arabic okay so I say to
myself so now I have a goal and and
actually he was gonna help us she's
gonna take our many stories at linked
and she's gonna record them in Egyptian
Arabic yes that would be my pleasure and
if I can get to where I understand it
then I gotta watch granite gentlemen
with my wife she has the subtitles and
then
goal is to visit Egypt and maybe you
should mention a little bit some of the
things to see in Cairo that people don't
they only know about the Giza that there
is a Jesus or what are some of the other
attractions well there are so many other
attractions depending on what sort of
thing that you like so if you are into
history and you want to see things like
the pyramids then there is also pyramids
in the shore and there is pyramids or
there are some other monuments that
exist in the area and Haram area which
is basically a little bit further away
from the pyramid goes by so they don't
really advertise those things that much
because they don't they are not as
attractive as the pyramids but if you
are into nature and things that are just
so beautiful and magnificent then in
Cairo you can go to my ID there is a
preserve there there's a mountain with
caves and everything which is dikhhla so
it's wonderful there it's so beautiful
so natural and it doesn't have that you
know it has that charm of nature
untouched and you are also suggesting
that it's a good time to go and travel
around other two areas from from Cairo
to be honest one
and look so not this one you're gonna
find of course so much history and so
many monuments to watch and things like
that but the trip itself is so
magnificent because you go through the
Nile so basically you watch everything
along the banks and there are villages
and there are lots of history that goes
along and and things that you would see
people and you would see life going by
but still holding to that same tradition
in that same culture and life so if
you're there definitely visit nubian
families they are gonna be so you're
gonna be so happy you're gonna learn a
lot there are magnificent people they're
so friendly so you're gonna do it there
you go
so that plus the fact that the Arabic
movie industry is essentially dominant
by Egyptian production so I'm gonna
decide that I'm gonna take my bottom
standard up to a certain point and then
I'm gonna start to focus on Egyptian
Arabic the intention of visiting one day
and hopefully visiting with you thank
you okay so they're gathered from the
lawn fest in Montreal
[Music]